nendaz a connu un déclin généralisé de
l'immigration ce printemps en raison des
restrictions sur les déplacements mais
il ya une reprise timide depuis le mois
de juin alors que le canada s'était fixé
pour objectif d'accueillir 341 milles
nouveaux arrivants cette année seulement
70% de ce nombre vont obtenir la
résidence permanente
j'en ai discuté hier avec line lagacé
vice présidente chez québec
international madame lagacé bonsoir
d'ossements alors évidemment toute cette
situation de pandémie a un impact pour
l'immigration quels sont vos
observations à cet effet là haut c'est
sûr lorsqu'on se retrouve dans une
situation où à cause de la pandémie des
frontières ont été fermées
c'est évident qu'il y aurait un impact
sur l'immigration et le pourcentage
immigration du canada
toutefois on se pose beaucoup de
questions sur le futur
actuellement on fait face à la marché du
travail est incomplète ébullition on a
des secteurs qui sont extrêmement
fragilisées ou avant on pouvait avoir
une certaine pression pour la main
d'oeuvre maintenant on en a plus on
pense au commerce au détail on pense à
la restauration l'hôtellerie
c'est même au niveau de la
transformation agroalimentaire ceux qui
sont rattachés à ajustement au niveau de
la restauration et l'hôtellerie
ces gens là n'ont plus cette pression
lol la pression est très très fort
toutefois sur la continuité des affaires
toutefois on a d'autres secteurs
d'activité qui au contraire actuellement
bon très bien et même la situation relié
à la pandémie a été pour eux une comme
une vague d'opportunités
ils leur ont permis d'aller d'aller vers
la croissance donc ces secteurs là
actuellement ont des besoins et grandes
sont malheureusement dans les
circonstances les gens qui sont
disponibles au travail les compétences
de ces gens là ne correspondent pas
toujours aux compétences recherchées un
secteur qui sont en demande d'où le
besoin d'aller et de continuer au niveau
de l'immigration
donc je crois que le l'immigration va
reprendre son rythme aux mêmes et vous
qu'on connaissait avant la pandémie
elle sera peut être transformée au
niveau des profils recherchés
mais c'est évident qu actuellement les
besoins sont là
y avoir quand même un retard dans
l'arrivée d'immigrants vous le disiez
les frontières sont toujours faits mais
est d'autant plus qu'ils aient toujours
délais en quelque sorte entre la demande
de permis l'approbation et l'arrivée
réelle des travailleurs à quel moment
est-ce qu'on va se sentir vraiment
l'impact kovy de 19 pour l'immigration
je pense qu'on peut considérer que dans
environ neuf mois on va sentir
effectivement 7,7 a hélas au niveau du
recrutement international parce que ça
prend environ neuf mois avant que les
gens qui sont recrutés puisse arriver
est effectivement sur les territoires
donc dans 9 mois est ici comme on aura
très peu frais de recrutement on va
sentir qu'effectivement il ya un creux
dans la rue gens qui proviennent des
territoires de d'ailleurs qu'ici sur le
territoire toutefois comme plusieurs
personnes ont dû retarder leur projet ça
va quand même arrivé il ya des gens qui
ont dû repousser ou les délais ont été
plus longs parce que il ya eu un arrêt
de traitement des dossiers même au
niveau de certains bureaux de visa les
gens ne pouvaient pas se rendre pour
aller faire enfin compte finaliser leur
dossier
donc ça va par an sauf quand même qu'on
va voir réapparaître aussitôt qu'une
ouverture des frontières va se faire on
va voir réapparaître des gens qui m'ont
arrivés de l'étranger venir s'installer
en mai dans neuf mois quand même sentir
un petit creux un petit creux au niveau
des arrivées est ce qu'on pourrait
penser à du rattrapage madame lagacé
c'est à dire augmenter le nombre
d'immigrants qui sont reçus pour combler
moi ou il y en a pas eu je ne pense pas
que au bout de la ligne ça va se
traduire par une augmentation
il va voir une transformation toutefois
déjà je vous donne un exemple on pense
beaucoup par exemple mon secteur de la
santé où on a vraiment on s'est aperçu
les besoins énormes qui avait dans ce
secteur là et même si le gouvernement a
essayé de faire une formation accélérée
entre autres pour les préposés aux
bénéficiaires
les besoins sont énormes moi je pense
qu'on va accélérer justement le
recrutement dans ce titre de profession
là mais dans d'autres professions on va
s'apercevoir que le besoin à diminuer la
pression est beaucoup moins fort donc la
demande va diminuer on mentionnait avant
la crise que c'est environ 20% des
emplois que devront être comblés par
l'immigration
sincèrement je crois qu'on va retourner
à ses 20% lors globalement on ne seront
probablement pas à 30% ou 40% mais on va
être 20% mais seuls 20% là va être
concentrée davantage dans certains
métiers ou dans certaines formations qui
vont manquer au québec
il est temps que l'on puisse adapter
vraiment les compétences des gens qui
sont au chômage par exemple aux
nouvelles réalités du marché du travail
mais ce délai leur va faire en sorte
qu'on devra recourir à l'immigration
pendant cette période vous parlez de
nouvelles réalités pour le marché du
travail je peux pas m'empêcher de penser
au télétravail madame lagacé est ce
qu'on pourrait penser à un monde dans
lequel on n'est pas en mesure de faire
venir physiquement des immigrants mais
on peut en embaucher davantage grâce
auquel ils travaillent de manière
virtuelle est ce que c'est une des
solutions selon vous c'est une solution
qui lui qui est déjà mis en place ce qui
est déjà vraiment utiliser et surtout
comme plus mentionné en début d'entrevue
il ya quand même un délai entre le
moment où la personne est embauchée et
le moment où est ce que ces personnes
n'a pu arriver sur le territoire non
comment on peut favoriser justement la
préparation de cet individu le à
distance
le télétravail nous a démontré dans les
derniers mois ont été en mesure d'être
extrêmement efficace et même dans
l'intégration de certains travailleurs
et même dans la formation de nouveaux
travailleurs
donc pourquoi pas commencer c'est toute
cette étape là
lorsqu'elle étudiait toujours sur le
territoire étranger et pour les
étudiants ont permis à madame lagacé la
hausse y aura un manque important
la majorité des étudiants ont prévu une
entrée en virtuel permettant à ses
étudiants de pouvoir débuter leur
session est de pouvoir penser venir
s'installer au québec par la suite donc
en termes d'inscriptions actuellement
oui il hilare probable certaines
personnes vont peut-être changer leurs
projets
mais sincèrement il quand même et nous
reprenons pour l'entrée scolaire de 2021
les activités de recrutement
international immédiatement donc ça se
fait actuellement en mode virtuel bien
sûr mais on redémarre toutes les
activités de recrutement international
donc je ne pense pas que y ait un trou
si énorme il mais il repart même des
impacts mais ce que ça l'est surtout
faire c'est que toutes les entreprises
toutes les institutions
peu importe d'où provient il a fallu
réfléchir à notre modèle d'affaires et à
nos pratiques d'apparat ce qui éclaire
madame lagacé c'est que malgré ce
contexte vous sembler optimiste on
l'entend très bien on arrêtait là dessus
je vous remercie beaucoup madame lagacé
merci à vous rendre à voir